[Musique]
je pensais au début que ça pourrait être
finalement au fur et à mesure que je
suis mis à réfléchir c'est devenu
beaucoup plus complexe parce que au fait
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient vraiment que
comme outil est ce qu'ils avaient
vraiment appris à thann et les po puis
aussi en fallait que ça m'arrange pour
que ça marche aussi la bosse après que
les comités soit un minimum confortable
fait que ça a été beaucoup plus complexe
que je pense et fait que j'ai comme
gosset avec du tissu au mètre carré main
et j'ai commencé par les mettre en pot
j'ai vraiment fait comme si j'avais dans
la chasse j'ai découpé dessus de façon
un peu organique aléatoire puis j'ai
fait des bobos puis j'ai rajouté des
épaisseurs parce que probablement qu
leur peau devait pas être très film j'ai
imaginé ni très fine ni très bien tanné
aussi je pense que je vais peut-être on
a des scènes d'hiver mais des scènes
d'automne il va être probablement
probablement beaucoup plus en pot
pupilles et beaucoup plus longtemps
qu'on compense mais je leur ai fait des
bottes parce que le jeu des comédiens
puis puis passé ils vont passer des
grandes oeuvres exposées à la tête des
conditions donc il fallait au minimum
confortable
[Musique]